Now, let's look at some examples of
how these metrics, session count,
session length, and retention can
really affect monetization in games.
First, let's consider a straightforward
example of a game that uses ads to make
money.
Now ads might not make the most money,
which we'll get into later, but
their success does depend on how often
and how long users play your game.
Because each time an ad
is displayed in the game,
it makes a small amount of money for
the developer.
And when there are a lot of sessions,
so the session count is high,
there will be a lot of
opportunities to display an ad.
Similarly, when a session is long,
ads might be displayed
multiple times in one session.
So both of these result in
more ads being displayed.
And more ads mean more money, and
retention looks at these effects
over a longer period of time.
Say, your app launches, and
people are excited about it.
There's a lot of sessions, but then
after a week or so, people start to get
bored with it, and the number of
players and sessions drops over time.
And when the number of sessions drop, so
does the amount of money the game makes.
So high retention is important for
monetization because your game will only
make money over time if you retain
a steady number of players.
Retention is especially important if
your game is planning on selling items
in the game over time.
These items are called in-app purchases
and include things like power-ups or
special game equipment that players
can buy and then use in the game.
And you want these sales to be
pretty consistent over time so
that you continue to make money.